Vale, al final lo dejamos en un estado.
Estábamos repasando en el día de ayer
las topologías de de red y las estábamos
haciendo en paquete.
No se ve el el comparto.
Vale, espera.
Estaría
ahora. Sí, ¿no?
Sí. Vale,
vale. Tendríamos este por aquí y
tendríamos este que lo tengo. Vale,
vale. Al final este
el de topología en árbol le pusimos IPS
eh hipers fijas. Lo que pasa que yo aquí
no recuerdo si si esto lo he hecho esta
mañana o lo dejé ayer, pero sí que puse
un servidor, creo que ha sido esta
mañana probando,
¿vale? Entonces, he puesto un servidor
que le he configurado
el DHCP para que
nos asigne direcciones IPs a los a los
diferentes dispositivos,
¿vale? Entonces estaría configurado para
que nos para que nos nos configure 18
direcciones IPs que que irían a partir
del del cinco,
¿vale? Y como tal, pues así lo he hecho.
¿Vale? Entonces, probando esto, luego
podremos,
a ver, luego cuando tengamos las
diferentes tipologías enlazaremos unas
con otras y tal. pequeña.
Vale, entonces cogemos esta, por
ejemplo, hasta aquí y vale, pues genial,
que nos nos lo hace, nos envía el
paquete.
Vale, hacemos otra prueba, por ejemplo,
de esta a esta y lo mismo,
¿vale?
Imaginaos todas estas redes como
diferentes salas de un,
o sea, diferentes departamentos,
¿no? Podría ser,
en los que se ha aplicado diferentes
configuraciones de red.
Vale,
vale. siguiente paso,
eh, vamos a crear una
una malla, que eso sí que lo estaba
mirando,
¿vale? Y luego haremos una
una circular esas o varios varias
circulares y luego trataremos de
interconectar entre todas ellas.
A ver, y podríamos a ver cuál
es que tenía por aquí una imagen.
Vale, tenamos esta
totalmente conexa y en maya realmente. O
sea, o sea, a la hora de
a la hora de representarlo,
lo que podría. A ver, lo voy a dejar por
aquí en chiquitillo,
¿vale? Realmente, o sea, ¿qué sentido
tiene que nosotros le pongamos aquí? Eh,
o sea, por ejemplo, ¿qué necesitaríamos
aquí? un
un dispositivo que nos admita varias
conexiones, ¿no? O sea, podríamos poner,
por ejemplo,
eh,
Vale, a mí lo que se me ha ocurrido ya,
a ver, he visto varias soluciones
propuestas por ahí por por internet y
tal, pero a mí lo que se me ha ocurrido
es esto, o sea, es en primer lugar crear
un server.
Luego si vosotros
pensáis alguna otra solución, pues la
implementamos también,
¿vale? Creamos un server que sería
máquina, sería una máquina de cliente en
este caso, y le configuramos una doble
una doble conexión. ¿Para qué? Para que
no tenga un solo punto. ¿Cuál era la
ventaja de una red en malla?
La principal ventaja, recordad,
la inexistencia de puntos débiles
realmente en toda la en todo lo que
sería la red, ese era su cometido,
¿vale? Entonces, eh si nosotros aquí
implementamos una segunda, una segunda
tarjeta de red,
a ver
si no pincho, como si no hago una. A
ver,
esta
esta creo que sería lo suyo porque esta
ya no esta es esta no sería esta de
aquí.
Vale, entonces traca a trac.
Vale, iniciamos el server. Vale,
entonces
tenemos esta por aquí, este, eh,
vale, tenemos el servidor aquí ya con
dos conexiones. Vale,
vamos a ponerlo aquí.
Bueno,
y ahora vamos a a llenar de swit todo.
Vale, podemos esto.
Vale, vamos uniendo los diferentes
dispositivos.
que estos serían dispositivos, lo
estuvimos viendo ayer, serían qué nombre
recibirían.
No, switch, o sea, evidentemente son
switch, pero ¿qué en qué categoría
estarían? ¿Serían dispositivos finales?
No
son dispositivos intermedios.
Enrotamiento también puede ser.
¿De qué?
enrutamiento o eso no no tiene que ver
con esto.
Hombre, serían de enrutamiento. Sí, sí,
porque realmente
si no atendemos a a su definición, sí, o
sea, realmente no se están no están
guiando realmente las los paquetes
porque,
o sea, yo me refería más a que a que son
dispositivos intermedios,
¿vale? más que a
más que a su función.
O sea, ¿os acordáis el el PowerPoint de
ayer que clasificaba los
componentes de una red en dos grupos?
Uno serían los APC, servidores,
teléfonos, etcétera, etcétera. Eran como
los sub o clientes o noos y toda la
cacharrería que que sirve para router,
switch, etcétera, etcétera, pues eh
todo esto serían eh los intermedios.
¿Vale? Aquí tendríamos una
pequeña red en malla. Y ahora lo que
vamos a hacer es que sea operativa,
porque ahora como que para qué, o sea,
esto no tiene sentido
conectar switch
porque sí tendría mucho sentido. Vale,
entonces
cogemos el el server que le hemos
añadido otra
otra tarjeta.
Vale, cogemos de aquí
C
V
y.
He cogido este porque en un PC no me
permite
o yo no he visto la opción de meterle
dos
de meterle una segunda un segundo puerto
CC. Una segunda tarjeta.
¿Qué va?
A ver, de aquí sí que me deja quitar
esta,
pero no hay. Hombre, estaría bien que
hubiera una tarjeta doble,
pero no nada.
Vale,
perdón. Vale.
Vale, que realmente aquí podríamos
también interconectar,
pero aquí ya se nos quedarían fuera de
esa red de malla. O sea, realmente la
conexión, bueno, sí, realmente sí que
tendría sentido la conexión de este PC.
A ver, vamos a ponerlo aquí también.
nube. ¿Por qué no?
Vale,
ahora coneríamos
Aquí en los servidores estos realmente
ya no tendrían más,
o sea, aquí sí que podríamos poner igual
un router interm, ¿no? Pero es que no
tienen mayor, no tiene más sentido. En
algún momento tienen que acabar, aunque
sea por muy malla que sea, ¿no?
Ya os digo, ahí he puesto servidores
porque es el que me permite meterle dos
tarjetas.
¿Vale? Eh, vamos a configurar este, por
ejemplo, o este de arriba, el primero,
lo vamos a configurar como un servidor
de HCP
por no ir poniéndole a todas las
a todos los dispositivos por no ponerles
una dirección. IP estática. Vale,
entonces activamos de CP.
Bueno, lo activamos ahora. A ver, aquí
vamos a eh
ponemos
espera,
su dirección IP sería
la
192.168
68 punto.
Ah, si luego lo quiero conectar va a ser
un jaleo. Bueno, por este no lo conectó.
Ya está. Punto uno, punto
dos, por ejemplo.
Vale, tenemos ese de aquí. Y ahora nos
vamos a los servicios
su puerta de enlace.
Sería la 1 192.168.1.1
DNS
ay, perdón, DNS nada. Aquí ponemos que
empiece a partir de la tres.
Vamos a hacerlo bien. Hay que tener este
seleccionado.
192.168.1
1.1
aquel lo he puesto como 1.2.
Este empezaría en la 1.3.
Decimos que la guarde,
¿eh? Y que nos cree pues, ¿cuántos hay
aquí? 1 2 3 4 5 6 7. Pues que nos cree
10, por ejemplo.
Vale. Y le decimos que guardar.
Su nombre sería ese. Lo ponemos activo,
¿vale? Y ahora en teoría estaría
preparado ya para
asignar direcciones IP. Ahí tenemos la
primera que nos ha asignado.
Aquí lo mismo.
y lo mismo.
A ver, de cara al examen, familiarizaros
con Paquet tracer, con la manera de
porque entre los nervios de
del día, porque quieras que no, pues
hombre, algo de nervios habrá, ¿no?
Que cada uno somos somos de una manera,
pero
pero generalmente en la en ocasiones así
como exámenes y tal, pues sí que tenemos
un poquito más de nervios. Bueno, a mí
me pasa, por lo menos.
Vale, ahora en teoría debería funcionar
y esto sí que sería una una
topología de malla.
Tenemos algunos
algunas zonas donde si este lo quitaba.
A ver, voy a quitar este.
Vale,
si este no entra por aquí, le entra el
paquete por aquí. Si este no entra,
igual es demasiado redundante, ¿no?
Y así está más optimizadito todo. O sea,
realmente
si eliminamos este dispositivo,
la red seguiría funcionando. Si
eliminamos este dispositivo,
la red seguiría funcionando, excepto
para este, que es el que depende
directamente.
O sea, a este le llegarían los paquetes
que este que este envía.
No es de una forma tan directa.
Vale, yo creo que así es más así es más
correcto.
¿Vale? Entonces, ¿qué sería? Por
ejemplo, eh vamos a a tirar un paquete
de aquí.
Tracatrá. Bien, ha funcionado
de aquí a aquí ha funcionado y de este
desde este PC
a este otro de aquí y vale, pues ha
funcionado.
Vale, esto sería una una topología
en malla válida para el ejercicio. otro
realmente,
o sea, si nosotros le añadimos aquí otra
más, es que tampoco estamos haciendo
nada,
¿eh?
O sea, no estamos aumentando tampoco la
eficacia, ¿no?
De esa red lo que os decía antes, o sea,
si no si esto no está tanto este como, o
sea, si está eh realmente lo que es es
más
digamos que sería como un desperdicio de
cable, ¿no? Realmente, o sea, realmente
es que tampoco nos aporta mucho más.
A ver, tiramos. Bueno, desde ahí hasta
ahí, ¿no? Desde aquí
tiramos desde aquí hasta aquí.
Aquí donde ha fallado este. No sé qué
sería. Vale,
tiramos de aquí. Aquí.
A ver, a ver.
Aquí. Aquí.
Vale,
o de aquí.
Vale, son todos correctos, pero
realmente
si nosotros, vamos a ver, vamos a
cargarnos un dispositivo
aparte de este cable de aquí,
¿vale? Si nosotros nos cargamos este
cable, por ejemplo,
¿creéis que le llegará a todos los
dispositivos?
Sí.
Sí,
porque realmente están unidos, ¿no? Por
por al final era lo que se buscaba con
con una con una topología en maya,
¿vale? Si nosotros nos cargamos este,
pues lo mismo. O sea, realmente, a ver,
nos cargamos ese cable,
otra cosa es que nos carguemos ya los
dos. Claro, eso ya no va a pasar.
Nos venimos aquí.
De todas formas, si quita los
hombre, si quitas este ya,
a ver, el resto de la red sí que
seguiría funcionando.
Vale, pero esta sí que sería válida para
a la hora de imaginar la pregunta.
dibuja en packet tracer o, o sea, o
implementa en Packet Tracer una una red
con porque dibujar con que dibujemos
cuatro elementos, lo que hablábamos
ayer, diferencias entre dibuja tal o o
implementa tal, ¿no? Implementa es
es que funcione.
Ya que hemos hecho los ejercicios
de esto, pues creo que es interesante
que los
que eso que los que los estudiéis,
¿vale? Y que sepáis luego cómo
implementarlos y qué elementos utilizar.
Aquí yo la verdad es que he visto
auténticas fricadas de buscando por
YouTube,
¿vale? con
de esto de maya, pero vamos a hacer la
vida más sencilla.
Vale,
vale. Venga, eh, que decir que a ver,
este es está tirando.
Si nosotros ahora uniéramos este
servidor,
este servidor a este router y pusiéramos
todos los estos estos dispositivos los
pusiéramos en DHTP
aumentando la cantidad de ellos,
podríamos tener una red, podríamos
podríamos implementar esto. O sea, es
que esto tend cuenta también a la hora
de
Bueno, esto en este caso sería árbol y
circular.
La de noble anillo realmente
no me queda clara. O sea, me entiendo
que es una como una doble un doble
cableado
en caso de fallo
por lo que he estado por lo que está
investigando y sí que podemos
implementarlo también aquí en en Packet
Tráfer. Vale, lo que os decía
es que a lo mejor podíamos y vamos
a hacerlo simplemente con vamos a poner
este en DHCP, ¿vale?
Y quizá el de al lado también. Vale. Y
este,
bueno, y el portátil este. Venga, va.
Vale,
vale, ya lo tenemos ahí. Ahora cogemos
de este switch.
Aquí le hemos dicho, eh, ¿cuántas le
habíamos dicho?
Ah, no, si es que era este. A ver, HTP.
Habíamos dicho que 10. Vamos a ponerle
15.
Sí. Vale, ahora nos venimos aquí
y con este router, con este swit,
perdón,
lanzamos porque aquí no tenemos más
conexiones ya. O sea, ahí teníamos los
dos puertos,
los dos puertos inutilizados. Aquí sí
podríamos poner un switch intermedio,
pero bueno, tiene mucho sentido tampoco.
Venimos aquí y enlazamos este con este.
Y ahora en teoría nos tendría que dar eh
nos tendría que asignar en esta red, en
estos dos elementos,
nos tendría que que asignar direcciones
IP. Y vamos a ver qué es lo que hace
con estas otras de aquí que sí que están
puestas en estática.
Y
pero les da a pipa, ¿no? Porque eh lo
tenías configurado para que de solo 10.
No lo he puesto los 10. No,
he puesto 15. Al final lo he cambiado.
Ah, vale. Finalmente
sí, sí, sí, lo he cambiado.
A ver, hay que esperar un poquillo.
Vale, aquí ya nos ha dado la 10
y aquí nos ha dado, aquí está
esperando y ahora nos nos pondrá la 11
posiblemente. Aquí, aquí está.
Vale, entonces tiramos paquete de yo que
sé de este a este
y okay. Vale,
pues eso,
o sea, lo digo porque imaginar la
pregunta, a lo mejor eh diseña una red
en la que
una red eh en malla en la que en una red
híbrida en malla y radial
estrella, ¿no? Esta sería estrella, pues
pues ahí tendríais una respuesta, una
posible respuesta. O sea,
configuraciones es que te puedes puedes
hacer un montón, eh, realmente.
Vale, este me lo cargo.
A ver.
Y estos los pongo como estaban porque
este archivito os lo pasaré.
Lo ponemos en estática. No me acuerdo
cuál cuál era.
192.168.
1 pun
52.
192.168.1
53.
Vale,
vale. Pues este este está claro, ¿no?
Aquí. Vaya, hombre.
Quería ponerlo así chulo todo.
Eh, color de
supongo que sería no me deja elegir.
Pues elijo
este posiblemente no es este de aquí. Es
más bien ese. Vale,
me vengo aquí.
viendo
y le vamos a poner también topología
maya
maya o también llamada
Estas figuras, la verdad es que están
bastante
bastante resvueltas con esto.
O sea, realmente
totalmente conexa
sí que podríamos poner una batería de
switch o dispositivos intermedios,
¿vale? Y luego en cada
en cada interconexión de ellos un
podríamos poner un cliente, un host,
pero bueno, o sea, así yo creo que así
nos vale ya.
Vale, siguiente paso. Eh, podríamos
hacer una en anillo.
Está sencilla. Y vamos a hacerla en
doble anillo también.
Esto, ¿qué pasa aquí? Porque se queda
os queda ahí debajo del virus este.
Vale,
vale. Vamos a hacer la de la de anillo,
por ejemplo.
Vale, que esta la podríamos hacer. Pues
mira, se me ocurre para que sea
totalmente funcional y no y no
utilicemos
y no utilicemos switch
de ningún tipo.
Lo que se me ocurre es que cojamos,
claro, como el PC con un PC no nos da la
opción, ¿vale? Entonces podemos el
servidor, meterle dos tarjetas.
Estoy mirando a ver.
¿Qué más hay aquí?
Nada, cogemos el cogemos un server al
fin y al cabo,
¿vale?
Lo configuramos pues como hemos hecho
antes.
Hm. Vale, es aquí.
Lo apagamos. Importante eh, cuando
tengáis que configurar, porque imaginad
que decimos en el examen, pues voy a
hacer tal, que sepáis cómo cómo hacer
esto,
¿vale? un server, por ejemplo, le
añades tarjeta. Aquí tienes un hueco
libre.
Vale, esto es como si lo estuvieras
haciendo realmente físicamente y luego
lo enciendes,
¿vale? Pero si encendido no te va a
dejar ni quitarlo ni hacer nada,
¿ves? O sea, imagínate que lo tienes
encendido, ¿vale? Y tú intentas y dices,
"Ostras, pues le voy a poner otra
tarjeta de Red." "Epa, no te no me
deja." ¿Por qué? Pues a ver, te está
poniendo que
que que no se puede añadir el módulo
cuando el cuando la fuente de
alimentación
está en marcha,
¿vale? Entonces, tú tienes que apagarlo.
Entonces le añades la tarjeta y luego lo
entiendes.
¿De acuerdo? Tener eso presente. Claro,
realmente en el momento que le pones una
segunda te aparece aquí, mira. Vamos a
quitarla.
Vale, nos venimos aquí. A ver, eh, vale,
iniciamos y en configuración solo
tenemos un una tarjeta de red.
Apagamos,
le añadimos la tarjeta. Familiarizados
con este menú de aquí también.
importante
porque suele ser bastante común en los
dispositivos, ¿vale? Y a lo mejor
queremos eh poner esto y ponemos otra
cosa. Entonces, esta sería la fase
ternet.
Entonces, iniciamos,
nos venimos a configuración y ya vemos
que tenemos las dos tarjetas activas,
¿vale? Acto seguido,
como vamos a hacer una recircular, lo
que vamos a hacer es copiar este
servidor y pegarlo tantas veces. Así no
tenemos que hacer esa operación todo el
rato. Imaginar que
para hacerla circular no vamos a
utilizar tres, vamos a utilizar mínimo
cuatro. Yo con cinco creo que es que es
mejor incluso.
Control C, control V, control V, control
V, control. Vale,
vale. Y aquí, por ejemplo, si se os
ocurre alguna otra alternativa,
decídmela, eh, conforme estamos
conforme estamos viendo esto.
Vale, al final lo he hecho de de seis.
Vale, ¿qué tipo de cableado irá de uno a
otro?
¿Qué será cruzado o cómo será este?
Vale, pues ahí tendríamos una red, eh,
aquí tendríamos Una una en anillo,
¿vale? Gerar, estas de esta de aquí
realmente
en árbol. Vale, vamos a hacer esta de
esta de anillo y luego vamos a hacer una
mista
más que,
o sea, diferente a esta que hemos
utilizado aquí allá. Vale, en toda
sería, vale, como lo hemos configurado e
realmente,
a ver, pongo así más chulo. Vale, ahí lo
está bueno,
eh vale, están para ponerlo en estática,
entonces nosotros habilitamos como ya
sabemos que para qué sirve de HCP, que
sería para,
¿recordáis para qué era?
para dar eh direcciones IP automáticas.
Correcto.
Vale, entonces aquí añadimos la puerta
de enlace.
Ay, espera, espera. Vamos a crearle
primero,
vamos a crearle primero una dirección IP
al servidor que sería este de aquí.
Vale, vamos a utilizar este como como
el, o sea, luego realmente la prueba a
no ser de que se os especifique,
eh, añade DHCP, eh, o sea, añade
direcciones automáticas
mediante DHCP, o sea, si lo queréis
implementar, genial, pero si no se si no
se especifica en el enunciado, tampoco
tenéis por qué
por qué ponerlas. Las ponéis fijas,
estáticas, ponéis una por una y ya está.
Vale, aquí en este caso sería el
servidor, sí que le añadimos su
dirección
192.168.1
punto
1, ¿vale?
Eh, la dirección de esta ensinamos
que queremos poner otro.
Vale, este lo vamos a poner como
Espera, estoy haciendo yo ahora.
Vale, vamos a dejarlo así. Sí, venga. Y
luego nos venimos aquí a def.
Vale, seleccionamos esto.
Aquí pondríamos 192.168.1.
Las de N se las dejamos punto un y aquí
que empiece a asignar a partir de la dos
a partir de la dos 15.
Ya nos asciende 15. Y tracmamos
el servicio.
Guardar.
Vale. Y
aquí,
hm, aquí en desop
ya empezamos a a asignarle,
o sea, poner los mudos de HCP para que
se le asigne
la dirección automática. Es que creo que
no he puesto.
A ver que me ha saltado algo.
Quizás porque has configurado eso para
la
fastner cero y hay que hacerlo en las
dos,
¿no? Porque lo he puesto. No, no, porque
el de DHCP sí que te lo envío.
Espera que creo que he puesto la puerta
enlace. Creo que está ahí el problema.
A ver, a ver qué es lo que he hecho.
Vale, aquí he puesto uno, uno. Vamos a
poner dos. Esta sería la dirección del
eh
del de esta máquina. ¿Vale? Luego nos
venimos aquí a config, o sea, yo aquí no
toco realmente en estas de aquí. Estas
no las toco.
¿Vale? Entonces
aquí en DHCP
le decimos que la puerta de enlace sería
la uno y que las direcciones las empiece
a enviar a partir de la tres porque este
ya sería la la número dos. Ahí, espera,
cambio esto.
Está encendido.
Vale. Y este ahora
pues venimos aquí en él, lo ponemos en
la estática.
Ahora sí que nos debería de
asignar dirección.
Chicos,
vamos a ver.
Me las está tirando todas.
está en modo de HD de HP tanto una como
como esta otra.
Esto es lo que decías tú que estaba en
modo estático.
Sí, sí.
A ver, a ver, que estamos fallando aquí
en Bueno, estoy fallando.
Vamos a ver.
Vale, tenemos
eh esto estaría en modo estático, ¿eh?
el 1.13
guardar. Voy a ver cómo ha configurado
esta.
Creo que era esta de aquí. A ver.
Vale, esta la había puesto como 1.2
y el de HCP 1.1,
¿vale? Y luego las
la configuración tanto de este como de
este está en estático.
Estático y estático. Puede ser que esté
ahí el problema que esté que esté como
de HTP, no sé por qué. Realmente,
a ver,
aquí está en HCP
y este segundo está en estático.
HTP y este primero
HCP
y estático. Está siguen todas el mismo
patrón.
Vale. Mm.
No es bueno copiar,
clonar las
realmente las No me acordaba yo de del
Vale, vamos a hacer vamos a empezar con
esta.
Vamos a continuar con Es que claro, lo
que tampoco quiero es hacer todo el
jaleo de de
añadir tanta
tanta tarjetita aquí
así una por una. Es que no es no es
eficiente eso. Vale, podemos hacerlo.
Vamos a hacerlo de la siguiente manera.
Vamos a utilizar este server.
A ver, un segundo, eh, voy a voy a mirar
las lo podíamos dejar en
la A ver, estas las podríamos a lo mejor
dejar en en modo
en modo automático
en vez de ir con, o sea, con el DHCP
activado simplemente, o sea, realmente
sí que nos serviría a modo de, vamos a
ver, o sea, quiero decir, a modo de
configurar una
de representar más de que configurar
una red, sí que podríamos, por ejemplo,
dejar
O sea, al final lo que se nos está
pidiendo es que representemos una una
red. Y aquí sí que podríamos dejar el
modo de HTP activado
en todos
y no dejaríamos de de
estar representando.
Mira,
este, este por aquí,
este por aquí.
por aquí
y este aquí. Bueno, entonces venimos
aquí,
¿vale? Estático, ponemos de HP,
¿vale? Los ponemos todos en modo
de CHP y realmente sí que tendríamos una
red.
Otra cosa es que asignemos las
direcciones también automática, o sea,
de forma estática, ¿vale? Eso también
serviría.
¿Has
conseguido
ponerlo
el qué?
Ah, no, nada. Que es que estoy
intentándolo también, pero tampoco me
sale,
¿no? A ver, mira, al final he optado
porque tú coges, o sea, realmente
estamos representando, ¿vale? Entonces,
esto es funcional. Hm,
porque me ha fallado. Espera,
posiblemente es que esté que esté
negociando. A ver, esta está en 16.
Vale, a ver.
Y si no, elegimos otra otra
configuración,
no pasa nada. Vamos a ver de aquí hasta
aquí.
Va bien. Vale, de aquí hasta aquí ya no,
ya falla. O sea, cuando lo hacé directo
va perfecto.
Cuando pasa por intermedio ya
no le gusta. Vale,
vale. ¿Cómo podemos solucionar esto?
Podríamos por ejemplo,
a ver,
este de aquí.
Vale, si cogemos este
es que lo tengo representado. Espera,
voy a esta.
Lo tengo en otro en otro pack tracer que
estuve haciendo y sí que me funciona.
A ver, ¿dónde lo he dejado? Aquí.
Vale, este realmente
este sí que este sí que está
funcionando.
Este
verde.
Vale, este me dice servidor
2 1 3 no tiene puertos funcionales,
¿eh? mientras que este y este sí que me
está funcionando.
Vale, una manera de solucionar esto
podríamos ejemplo, o sea, aquí
estoy viendo que de aquí a aquí sí que
me lo sí que lo pasa,
sin embargo,
otras config, o sea, por ejemplo, este y
este no,
de este a este sí, o sea, ahí sin
problema.
Vale, a ver qué podemos hacer.
Nos podemos cargar este,
nos podemos cargar este también.
Y bueno, nos realmente nos cargamos
todo, ¿vale? Entonces, a ver, vamos a
crear aquí una
un switch.
Aquí nos eh cogemos este,
cogemos otro aquí,
otro aquí
y otro aquí. Vale, añadimos un PC, por
ejemplo,
aquí.
y añadimos un PC
Vale, Jas.
Es me gustaría tener algún tipo de
dispositivo que que hiciera las veces de
del server este.
A ver, aquí están todos. A ver cómo
están.
Ponemos en DHP.
DHCP,
¿vale? Y este también.
Y este lo tenemos en A ver,
¿vale? entiendo que ahora debería de
Vale, ahora sí que funcionaría
todos los dispositivos de la red. Claro,
en el momento, o sea, al final,
imaginaos que este switch realmente,
o sea, no os fijéis, o sea, quiero
decir,
imagínate esto así, ¿vale? Sí, son dos
son dos dispositivos,
pero realmente
imagínate que lo tenemos que lo tenemos
junto al ordenador o que o que tenemos
dos dos tarjetas en este ordenador,
¿vale? Entonces sí que nos debería de
poder funcionar. No entiendo aquí por
qué no nos va.
Igual es porque ha ido ahí poniéndolo
automático las
A ver, esta de la uno
quizás si lo hiciera.
A ver, voy a probar a voy a probar a
hacer este.
O sea, realmente esto sí que sería una
una red circular,
¿vale? Una una topología circular.
del mismo modo que este. Voy a intentar
ponerlos
mediante, a ver, de la cero
nos vamos a la cero,
por ejemplo, eh, por ser ordenamos de la
uno,
de la uno nos vamos a la 1,
de la cero nos vamos a la cer
y de la Uno, nos vamos a la uno.
Tenemos la pipa en todas.
Bueno, en esta no todavía
tenemos,
aquí tenemos.
Igual es que esta no está configurada.
Vale,
ahora sí.
Igual no iba por eso.
Bueno, bueno,
eh,
y ahora tiramos de aquí. A ver.
Vale, me voy a cargar todos.
Vale,
vale, tenemos este.
Perfecto.
Creo que es que no estaba configurado
ese otro.
No, este va a dar fallo.
Vale, este da fallo.
Estos van bien. Claro, se comunica
perfecto con el que tiene al lado, pero
con este ya
dice que no hay.
Vale, estaría bien. Eh,
voy a intentar resolverlo luego a la a
la noche mañana a ver si lo si tenemos
dos configuraciones buenas para para
representar. Vale, estaría bien
porque a ver,
a ver si yo le digo desde aquí que me
envíe ahí,
o sea, desde aquí. Aquí sí que funciona
esto. ¿Qué es?
y de y a la inversa no funciona.
O sea, de aquí a aquí no va
de aquí a aquí funciona.
Entonces de aquí
a este primero también y a la inversa sí
que estaba funcionando también.
El único camino que no hace es este. Sí.
A ver si lo dejamos resuelto para para
mañana, aunque mañana no tenga, pero
como estamos así un poquito en en plan
repaso con todo.
Vale, está en plan dispositivo. Sí que
podríamos sí que podríamos
utilizar.
A ver, vamos a ver el camino que que
toma.
Vale, nos venimos aquí, le decimos que
nos la traiga hasta aquí. Vale, entonces
vamos
de aquí a aquí.
Vale, entrega el paquete. Perfecto. Pues
ahora nosotros nos cargamos, por
ejemplo.
Yo estaba intentando hacer eso y me
parece que Cisco ya estaba pensando,
"Riéndete y se me ha cerrado.
Yo voy a intentar ahora." Claro, porque,
o sea, él realmente coge este camino y
le va perfecto, pero la topología de red
circular nos dice que que bueno que se
que puedo otro camino, ¿no?
Entonces, lo que voy a es que me
voy a cargar este cable de aquí
simulando una rotura. Yo que sé, porque
¿por qué? que sí, este cable de ahí y
ahora realmente lo tendría que traer por
aquí, ¿no?
Vale, entonces a ver, de aquí hasta
aquí, aquí ya dice que que no hay. Vale,
pues esta no sirve.
Esta no nos serviría como como ejemplo.
¿Vale? Entonces
espero poner poder tener tiempo y
echarle un vistazo, ¿eh? Y que mañana lo
veamos, porque sí que sí que está
estaría interesante esto, que se
solucione, ya que no lo hicimos en su
día,
¿vale? Me dice que andan ahí. Si yo
ahora le pongo, por ejemplo,
vamos a ver,
le añado una estática que sería 192.168
1.2.
Vale,
añado un servidor eh
http.
Selecciono esto, le digo que que lo
active, lo guardo.
Puerta de enlace 1 2 6 8
y aquí que empiece en la tres, por
ejemplo, y que me haga seis.
A ver, creo que lo ha puesto todo.
Vale, vale. Entonces, ahora aquí decimos
que
queremos HCP.
Está revoltosillo.
Aquí sí que lo coge.
Aquí no entiendo por qué no sé que
debería de de
pillarlo.
A ver,
Dios.
poniéndola la misma que la del servidor.
Está mal, qué mal.
Me lo cargo,
eh.
No, no nos no nos va a servir esto.
No nos va a servir. Aquí sé que podíamos
por ejemplo.
No, no, no, no nos sirve,
no nos sirve y ya está, pasa nada.
Vale, voy a intentar mañana tenerlo
tenerlo porque la verdad es que es una
lástima.
Podríamos utilizar a lo mejor el Claro,
o sea, aquí lo fácil sería a lo mejor
este, el eh
cacharros de estos que tiran para hacia
todos los lados. A ver.
Pero es que yo no quiero esto tampoco.
Sí.
Vale. Y aquí para hacerlo bien, aquí
tendríamos que tener otro
top C, por ejemplo. Y vamos a ver ahora
este sería la 1.2.
Este estaría todavía pillando. A ver.
está
que la 1.3
Y si ahora traigo un PC por aquí
y lo unimos
aquí
a ver qué nos hace fe.
Vale, aquí se con los sí sé sí que nos
deja sé que nos dejaría hacerlo.
Aquí sí que no va a haber problema,
pero yo no quiero utilizar estos
dispositivos.
O sea, aquí sí que tenemos conexión
realmente con con absolutamente todo.
De hecho, si ponemos
Yo estoy intentando,
sí, dime.
Del, bueno, del server uno al al, o sea,
del cero al uno
sí que me da bien, pero luego cuando
intento pasar al tercero me pone un a
pipa.
Eso es lo que me estaba pasando a mí
también.
Pero la que estás con switch, ¿no? Yo he
cambiado Hub,
¿no? O sea, estoy intentando hacerlo lo
de la derecha.
Esto de aquí,
sí,
esto de aquí, ¿verdad? Es que este es el
interesante que narices porque es puro y
duro el
Claro. Y me está dando eso que te digo.
Es lo que me pasa a mí, es lo mismo,
¿eh? O sea, porque mira,
están incluso cuando están dos en la
pipa tampoco me deja, o sea, tampoco hay
conexión realmente entre todos.
Vale, entonces déjame este, déjame darle
una vuelta que que lo sacamos seguro.
A unas malas
esto no serviría.
O sea, realmente
esto sí que sería una una red
con matices
circular.
Realmente sí, o sea, realmente es que
tenemos que utilizarla con esto. O sea,
es que es con esto. Esto es con Sí.
cogido con pinzas sí que sería, vale,
una red circular, pero realmente creo
que es eh la definición correcta sería
algo así, un dispositivo con una entrada
y una salida que conecta con el
siguiente y con el anterior.
Esa esa es la definición. Al fin y al
cabo,
aquí tenemos
un dispositivo intermedio,
tenemos el el cliente final que solo
tiene una entrada con él, o sea, en el
momento que que
A ver, ¿cómo cómo sería esto,
espera que lo pongo en DCHP,
me coge dirección. Genial. Y este
también.
coge dirección,
¿vale? Y ahora esto sí que sería
completamente funcional todo, ¿vale?
Incluso con el servidor emitiendo
emitiendo direcciones IP,
¿vale? Pero no entra dentro de lo que
sería la de que se lo que sería la
definición de una de una red, de una
topología circular.
La topología, la perdón, la topología
circular sería esto de aquí,
que también os digo que si nosotros
quitamos,
o sea, realmente esta parte sí que sí
que está funcionando, ¿vale? O sea, si
nosotros cogemos de aquí, enviamos aquí,
nos da correcto.
Vamos a ver.
Si nosotros cogemos aquí y enviamos
aquí, nos da correcto. Si cogemos de
aquí y tiramos para aquí, nos da
correcto. Y si tiramos de aquí y vamos
hacia aquí también nos da correcto.
¿Dónde está el fallo? Aquí. O sea, si de
aquí hasta aquí nos da correcto, pero a
la inversa
nos dice que ni de coña.
¿Vale? Entonces a lo mejor cogiendo y
cargándonos este
nada nos está diciendo que tengan que
ser todos los dispositivos lo mismo,
¿no? Entonces, vamos a ver, nos cargamos
este server.
Perdón.
Y le metemos aquí
un switch,
¿vale? Y
a ver qué a ver qué onda.
con este y aquí con este
realmente
se Vamos a ver a ver cómo funciona esto.
Hombre, lo ideal sería hacerlo eso con
todo, todo serví todo. Dispositivos con
entrada y salida,
dispositivos finales con entrada de
salida.
Vale, cogemos este de aquí y este de
aquí. Perfecto.
Por lo que estoy viendo, eh, hay una
limitación y y no puede ser en plan, no
se puede pasar del del segundo servidor,
no se puede pasar de del como el
segundo.
¿A qué te refieres? Cuando conectas el
el que da la eh IPS a uno sí que da,
pero si ese lo conectas al siguiente ya
da eh a pipa.
Vale, pero aquí sí que me está
funcionando. O sea, mira este.
Ah, vale, que está bueno, está en la
pipa.
Yo realmente los tengo en una pipa
todos. Sin embargo, luego nos venimos
aquí a la a esta y aquí tenemos un
servidor
de de HCP.
que nos está emitiendo y está generando,
pero eh es por por los switches que que
hay en medio.
Sí.
O sea, realmente necesitamos de los
intermedios, ¿no?
Sí, sí.
Para
eh
para añadir, por lo que he estado viendo
es para como añadir delay y que llegue
la dirección bien.
O sea, que técnicamente no se pueden
conectar. todos directamente hacer eso.
Yo lo voy a conseguir.
Que sí,
yo lo voy a conseguir. Ya te digo yo que
sí.
Vale, entonces eh porque a ver
esta serviría es que o sea, a ver, la
definición realmente de una red circular
nos está hablando de que si aquí corta
se puede comunicar por el otro sitio,
¿no? O sea, el camino el camino más
corto sería este para llegar hasta aquí.
Pero si aquí cortamos este cable
y aquí sí que tendría, espera a ver.
Vale, vamos a probarla.
Sería por ejemplo del server
aquí.
Vale, perfecto. Vale, entonces ahora nos
cargamos esta conexión,
¿vale? y le decimos del server hasta
aquí y perfecto. Nos ha servido tanto
este camino como este.
Entiendo que el primero que ha pillado
es el corto, ¿no? Sería sería lo lógico.
De hecho, a ver,
lo podemos ver atendiendo a eso sí que
podría ser una definición buena,
pero por la propia
por la propia morfología de los de los
cap, ¿no? Si aquí posiblemente le
metemos.
La cosa es que eh ahora he puesto
dime
eh seis servidores y un switch en medio
de cada uno y tampoco funciona. Entonces
yo ya no no entendí nada.
¿Dónde has puesto el switch? En medio de
cada, o sea, aquí.
Bueno,
sí,
vale. Entre en medias, ¿no?
Sí. O sea, ha hecho un círculo y es
servidor switch. Servidor switch.
Claro, realmente lo más parecido que
tendríamos sería sería algo así, ¿no?
Que es,
o sea,
pero solo me lo da a una. Entonces, no
no sé.
Claro, yo atendiendo a la definición,
esto podría ser, ¿vale? ¿Por qué? Porque
si cortamos, o sea, la definición de de
una red circular, de una topología
circular, es que o bien por un camino o
bien por otro te van a llegar los
paquetes.
Es esa, o sea, no es otra. ¿Vale?
Entonces aquí sí que sí que se cumple,
o sea, servidor hubs y los PC,
o sea, aquí se cumpliría, sí, porque, o
sea, vamos a ver qué sentido tendría
esto,
o sea, esta de aquí, ¿qué sentido
tendría? Todo, todo
claro,
ya
no tiene sentido, ¿no? Eh, siempre tiene
que haber un punto en el que te, o sea,
siempre tiene que haber un bus aquí.
que en este caso sería sería,
o sea, que quiero quiero decir este
ramal de aquí, o sea, es la conexión que
tiene hacia la red este cliente
y así así a la vez en todos. O sea, ¿por
qué? Pues porque nosotros en cualquier
cliente no tenemos dos tarjetas de dos
tarjetas de red, solo tenemos una.
Entonces, ¿cómo nos podemos conectar de
dos a una entrada y una salida?
Eso es lo que hay que despejar para
hacer esta para hacer esta esta
configuración sin este, o sea, metiendo
aquí otro servidor o incluso más,
¿vale? Y eso es lo que me luego me
pondré a ver que después de cenar me lío
ahí con el el cacharro este
a ver qué consigo.
Vale, si queréis lo dejamos lo dejamos
aquí y
me echa un poco de humo a la cabeza, la
verdad.
Vale, bueno, por lo menos hemos
avanzado, ¿no? Un poquito también con
esto porque ya tenemos
tenemos configurada esta y a falta de
hacer una que
a ver, es que sí, esta está bien, pero
con pinzas, ¿vale? O sea, yo no
sí me sí acepto pulpo, pero no
pero no del todo,
pero a falta algo mejor. Esto es lo que
tenemos, ¿vale? Y y yo creo que esto es,
vale,
además está ahí con su DHTP y todo eso,
¿vale? Eh, topología circular, lo pongo
por aquí y no las marco todavía. Topo,
no se no merece topología
circular.
Mira, según Gémini,
dime el Gémini a ver qué dice el señor
Gémini.
La razón es que una conexión directa
entre aeropuertos Ecernet de los
servidores causarían un un bucle de red
y los mensajes de difusión del de HCP no
se pueden repartir correctamente.
¿Vale? Entonces, ¿qué sentido tiene esa
topología circular?
Claro.
Pues con servidores ninguna. con
servidores ninguna, pero con PCs o con
Switch, o sea, entonces sería esto.
A ver, con PC sí que tiene más más
sentido,
pero digo yo que cómo lo pones el PC,
porque el PC solo tienes solo tienes una
entrada
para determinar.
Bueno, yo tengo dos, por ejemplo,
en la en la placa.
Yo sí, yo sí que tengo dos en una placa
de en el sobremesa, pero
pero no es lo habitual, ¿no? Tú ahora
miras tu portátil y ves que tienes un
eterno.
Sí.
Entonces, ¿qué haces ahí? Que le metes
un una doble, una clavija doble.
Vamos a investigar por ahí a ver cómo a
ver cómo podemos representarla bien.
Vale. Es que realmente no, o sea, parece
la más sencilla,
pero no es la más sencilla, ¿eh? de
coña.
Vale, pues esta la dejamos así en
en rojillo.
Stand by
me pone, "Es imposible conectar cuatro
servidores directamente en una topología
de de anillo."
Vale. El Gémini, ¿no? Te lo pone.
Sí. Ahora sí que estoy tirando de aquí
porque si no me vuelvo loco.
No, no, que sí, claro. Sí, eso es
configuración hace un bucle de red, lo
cual eh provoca una inundación
de bueno, sí, de eh tráfico y colapsaría
la red.
Vale, lo que podíamos decirle es de, a
ver,
mira, aquí pone montaje en Packer, eh,
dispositivos, un router, por ejemplo,
modelo, no sé qué y cuatro servidores.
Un router y cuatro servidores, pero el
router puesto también aquí, ¿no? en la
en la
Eso es lo que no había contemplado yo,
el poner, o sea, imagínate en vez de
este switch un router, ¿no?
Sí, pero la cosa es que sería el router
el que da la direcciones, ¿no?
Sería el router el que dan las
direcciones. ¿Lo llegamos a hacer o no
implementarla mediante consola?
Sí,
de hecho tengo los comandos aquí
guardados. Puedo pasar.
Ah, genial. Genial. Pues eso está eso
está guay también. Vale.
O no, o no me lo Vale, sí, está aquí.
Yo los tengo por aquí también, ¿eh? No,
yo es que quería saber si estuvimos
hablando de si lo habéis visto vosotros
eso. Claro,
lo he pasado. Si quieres puedo intentar
hacer cuatro servidores en R. Claro,
no sé si lo hará, pero si
no, hombre, si estamos aquí para eso.
A ver,
server.
Vale, lo voy a intentar yo también.
La cosa es que el servidor que se
conecte al router no se va a poder
conectar al otro servidor y cerrar el
círculo porque no tiene tantas
tantas.
El router sí que tiene dos sí que tiene
las otras dos salidas, ¿no? Pero sería
un server con como lo hemos implementado
con las dos tarjetas.
A ver,
o sea, yo sí que lo veo viable.
Copiar, pegar, copiar, pegar, copiar,
pegar. A ver.
cuatro y ahora un router.
Pero claro, es escucha, al server ese sí
que le tienes que añadir la tarjeta.
Sí, sí. O sea, he hecho un servidor con
dos tarjetas y heado y pegado el mismo
servidor.
Vale, vale.
Y luego estaba el router PT este que
tiene que se le puede añadir PT router.
Vale, bueno, aquí realmente tenemos dos,
chicos, ¿por qué no?
Vale, ¿qué qué router cogemos?
P este el PT. Sí, este va bien
porque es que luego está. A ver,
he pillado el 2911 que es el que me pone
Gémini de de ejemplo.
Vale,
así que si no funciona es culpa de
Géminis.
El 2911 tiene, a ver,
tiene dos puertos
en
y luego tenemos este que tiene eh el PT
tiene dos tiene dos fases etern
y nos deja y nos deja meterle otros dos,
o sea, porque estos que tienen
ahora es
dime
en configurador terminal.
Sí, en CLI
interface inter.
Vale, ahora le dices enable.
Sí, enable. Configure terminal interface
fast.
Fast.
A ver dónde estaba. Que sí que lo has
mandado por aquí. A ver.
Solo que como hay tantas líneas no
termin de entender nada. Espera,
vale. Eh,
vale. Lo a ver realmente lo primero, o
sea, para mira, la configuración del del
DHCP está en el en la segunda
en el segundo párrafo, como si
dijéramos.
Sí,
vale. Porque esto primero sí que lo
puedes hacer en modo
esto primero.
Sí. Pues es que lo primero no lo
entiendo,
no es que lo primero simplemente es
decirle
lo primero es esto, o sea,
la IP que tiene, ¿no?
La IP de cada de cada tarjeta.
Eso sería.
O sea, que eso me lo puedo saltar y le
puedo poner la IP.
Podrías añadirle. Sí, sí, yo creo que
sí. Podrías añadirle una IP,
o sea, la de HCP.
192.168.1.1
click.
Bueno, no.
Vale, ahora no sé cómo sal aquí.
Exit.
Vale, roto. Esto lo guardo
aquí lo mismo. O sea,
quiero decir
se os ocurre cualquier otra
configuración que funcione,
implementarla. O sea, que esto tampoco
es,
esto es lo que hemos ido haciendo. Yo he
visto realmente auténticas eh burradas
con esto, con la de
con la topología en maya.
Lo que no he visto tantas realmente es
de estas, eh, cuando me he puesto ahí a
buscar
de estas de circular,
parece como que ¿Qué tal? ¿Cómo va,
Jorge?
Intentando poner los comandos.
¿Por dónde vas?
Default.
A ver, a ver, router,
comparte si quieres.
Voy un segundo. Un se
voy.
Esto, a ver,
en teoría ya lo tengo configurado, pero
el qué,
el de HCP. Vamos a ver si funciona. Sí,
sí que funciona.
Sí que te ha funcionado.
Y a ver si al siguiente sí que tira
también
a pipa.
Ahí ahí se apipa.
A este. No, no llegará ya tampoco.
Es no llega. Pues igual hay que poner un
router intermedio o algo, no sé, o un
switch o algo así.
el virus este
M.
Este, no,
esa estaba en Apipa también. Ese otro
server.
Sí, el de abajo. Sí,
sí.
A ver, esperemos que se conecte esto. Si
está así, no, no va.
No, si está así, no.
Y este ni de coña. Ese no estáendo.
Ese no está yendo. ¿Por qué? Porque
porque mira, como tienes dos.
A ver, ¿cómo se diría est? A ver, ¿qué
es lo que has implementado? Puedes irte
a config.
Config.
Vale. Tienes 0 1. Ah, es que está están
en Gibal. Ah, Cernet
no tiene.
Ostras, claro.
A ver si este va ahora con el switch en
medio y si no ya yo me mato.
Mañana más y mejor, hombre.
No va,
no. Déjalo.
Pues nada,
déjalo. Vamos a investigar. De todas
maneras, ese router, ¿no?
El el PT router es el es lo suyo por
utilizar aquí. Y luego hay otro que es
el,
a ver,
eh, 2911 1. A ver.
No, este tampoco.
Tal cualidad. O sea, a mí, a ver, el PT,
el router PT está bien.
Este, a ver,
PT que tiene las fas. Es lo suyo.
Este sería lo suyo. Mañana lo lo
tratamos de de resolver. Da igual. O
sea, estamos en modo repaso un poquito
con todo.
Vale, esto lo guardo
y
como lo vamos haciendo aquí. Hombre, si
si encuentras la solución, estupendo,
Jorge.
Pero yo la voy a buscar también hoy.
Intentaré, pero es complicado,
¿no? Bueno, esto a ver, yo igual digo
tal y luego hago así y me quedo y me
quedo frito, ¿sabes? Que es que es
posiblemente sea lo que me pase y mañana
por la mañana sí que lo busque, no sé.
Pero sí que me gustaría, ¿vale? el el
que porque esta solución, a ver, vale,
está ahí parece un híbrido, ¿no? Así un
poquito parece una solución mi
acaba de no me acaba de convencer.
Sí que funciona. Es totalmente
funcional, pero no me no me no la veo.
Vale, venga,
a ver qué ha pasado aquí con tanta foto
y tanta cosa.
Vale, ahora tengo sistemas operativos.
Vamos a cogernos. ¿Habéis hablado con
con Pilar del examen y todo eso?